después de meses de encarcelamiento el
sabor de la libertad llega para algunos
de los soldados capturados por Rusia el
miércoles Ucrania anunció la liberación
de 215 militares en el mayor intercambio
de prisioneros desde el inicio de la
guerra
hoy tenemos 215 buenas noticias Esta es
definitivamente una victoria para
nuestro país y para nuestra sociedad
pero sobre todo para las 215 familias
que podrán ver a sus seres queridos
sanos y salvos en total 108 combatientes
del Batallón 188 Héroes de asoftal y
Mario Paul 8 que resultaron heridos
después del ataque terrorista ruso en
olenista
muchos de los liberados fueron
capturados durante el asedio de asoftal
incluidos 5 comandantes donde muchos
Soldados ucranianos del Batallón
resistieron durante semanas a las
fuerzas rusas en Mario pool como parte
del acuerdo Ucrania liberó a 55
prisioneros dentro de los que destaca
Víctor mevetshock ex legislador
ucraniano y estrecho de Putin detenido
en abril fue uno de los fundadores del
partido Pro ruso partido de la oposición
por la vida
como resultado de un difícil proceso de
negociación 55 militares de las fuerzas
armadas de Rusia y las fuerzas de la
repúblicas de donex y lugans han sido
devueltos de los territorios ucranianos
controlados porque sus vidas estaban en
riesgo mientras estaban en cautiverio
todos han sido transportados en un avión
militar a Rusia
en el intercambio también fueron
liberados prisioneros extranjeros
gracias a un acuerdo negociado con
Arabia Saudita 10 hombres aterrizaron en
riad el miércoles por la noche cinco
británicos dos estadounidenses un croata
un marroquí y un sueco
uno de los británicos Eden Slim Fue
capturado por fuerzas respaldadas por
los rusos en abril y posteriormente
condenado a muerte al igual que el
marroquí brahim Sudán capturado en
donesk se espera que todos los liberados
regresen a sus respectivos países en los
próximos días